the man accused of killing reputed mob  boss Frank Calley shared an apparent  political message in his first court  appearance wearing a green and white  prison jumpsuit 24-year old Anthony  Camello waived extradition from New York  from New Jersey rather to face murder  charges here in New York  he often yawned and smirk during the  process he displayed something written  on his left palm it said this Mogga  forever  that's an abbreviation of President  Trump's campaign slogan make America  great again it also read united we stand  manga and patriots in charge  Camela allegedly shot cali outside his  staten island home last week